whether Sampath cannon at pen a hon and
ma soul who sins and moved to MIT and
swagger Sanyal who actually since then
he moved to one of the I 80s alright so
let me start what are some definitions
so even though I said we can discussion
we'll find it feels mostly we're going
to be sketching over the field of two
elements because it's the most basic
example and is gonna help us keep the
notation relatively simple and so let me
introduce this first definition of what
I'm going to call f2 sketching so
imagine we have a binary input X in 0 1
to the n then the parity is just a
linear function that computes sum over
of 2 of a bunch of bets and today I'm
going to be also be using notation quite
a bit instead of just thinking the sum
over up to 1 could be you know I'm
putting this a circle plus sign sort of
an ax or off a bunch of deaths over up
do the same thing and our first
definition is going to be a
deterministic linear sketch
deterministically in your sketch is just
a collection of K parity functions so
you you take your ax you compute a bunch
of Perry's by taking sums over K fixed
subsets of of M and you get this values
of these berries so a bit of terminology
today I'm going to call this number K
the dimension of this sketch and for the
case of F 2 the dimension is basically
the same as the bit complexity of
storing the sketch itself right because
each each value of the sketch just takes
a single bit to store so dimension and
the size are for active sketches are the
same if you're going to increase your
field size to say FP then dimension and
the sketch size are going to differ by a
factor of log P
all right so that's a deterministic
linear sketch and you know the cleaner
sketch is very simple you just take a
collection of parodies or of certain
pets of your input so now this leads to
our two introduces this definition of a
randomized linear sketch which is a
distribution over K parity functions so
you pick random subsets as one through
SK and you compute the parodies over
these subsets so if you remarks here in
a randomized New Year sketch you can
pick your subsets from one single joint
distribution over all these subsets so
the subsets do not have to be chosen
independently there is one joint
distribution of them that generates this
collection of subsets all right so far
so good this is kind of like an
important definition so I just want to
make sure that all right so that's a
randomized linear sketch here
and the central question is imagine we
have some function f of X what we want
to know is can we recover f of X from a
small linear sketch over or some final
field let's say f 2 and by small I mean
K should be much much less than n
because obviously F if K equals n then I
can just compute every individual bit as
a sketch and that gives me the entire
input and then I compute f of X all
right so the question is can we make
these dimension K to be much much
smaller than n and still recover f of X
and again a few remarks here here let's
say we allow some success probability
say 99% so you can do this in a
randomized fashion where the probability
is taken only over the choice of random
sets for now and does not depend on the
input so this guarantee should really
hold for every fixed X so you're going
to assume that these sets that have been
sampled from this Joint Distribution are
known at recovery time and without loss
of generality you can assume that the
recovery process is deterministic right
so so the running time for us to be is
not going to be a concern so we only
going to be focused on on the dimension
of the space just 1 right so you just
compute that so that's that's it this
marker right here so the SADS algemene
known to you at the recovery time
so the query Authority query to nicotine
our
Perley query complexity so for parity as
as my new pointed out you know that the
dimensions can be just one right you you
compute just the single parity and that
gives you K equals one oh yeah sorry
yeah so parity query complexity I think
should be a lower bound in this case
because parity code complexity basically
is gonna be sort of a I guess in 30 K
program back so you also like can do
this adaptively yeah this is sort of a
non adaptive for shooting so via but
that would be okay any other questions
great
and um you know if you entertain some of
you if you maybe find this rock to be
simple like you stated an open problem
upfront so that you can carry some in
mind and you know if you manage to solve
this then oh that's going to simplify a
lot of things in this line of work
all right so what is the open problem so
the open problem is going to be a
communication problem in this
communication problem we have two
players Alice and Bob Alice holds an
input X in 0 1 2 p.m. Bob Paulson you
put Y in 0 1 to the M and they have
access to shared randomness the creation
problem is just a simple one-way
communication problem where Alice just
to send in a single message to Bob this
message M of X and so far this is just
the general one-way communication
complexity setup except that the
function f is a little special the
function f is what is called an XOR
function of the two inputs I function f
is defined to be some other function of
X plus y first consensus with no
separation its entirety working city and
the dimension K for some reason
ah that is a good question I'm not sure
maybe someone else decision stream oh
okay yeah sure yeah maybe the question
is just the good question it was just as
I didn't hear the question I'm asking
what separation okay actually actually
the outside guesses maybe maybe just an
advanced function would be a good
example right now that not anything
about it um I think that address
function it is simple for for parity
query complexity right because it would
have like parity or complexity log log n
basically that's sort of the difference
between document non-adaptive I guess
right and in this setting as we're going
to see yeah so Adam don't often think
about parity query complexity that's why
I'm like a little a little rusty on that
um but yeah so that would be would be an
exponential separation like Morgan
versus having basically okay
all right so uh so let's go back to this
weekend shoe problem the the conjecture
here is that um let's say in almost a
shortest message in this communication
game uh has to be a randomized in your
sketch or can be a randomized the inner
scale essentially uh the contracture is
that there is nothing better than that
Alice can do that just to send a bunch
of parody is to Bob
and so this is an open problem on on a
collection of open problems in somebody
an algorithm is sub-linear dot info so
why do you think almost it's after a
constant factor or even better worse um
right so as far as I know this can hold
even up to like a constant factor or
even maybe it was like some small
additive error would like no no loss in
a constant factor but they want to put
this as almost to just encourage people
to prove something but maybe like it
right so the revision would still be
pretty interesting this is s require to
be like potential function there or you
have something like promise on the B
inputs oh I'm sorry is it again to have
like some promise on the inputs or is
like F required to be defined everywhere
yeah so this is a total function and
that's actually important for non total
functions I think this is totally false
there's gonna be an exponential
separation again using some version of
generalized address function for for non
total functions that's kind of um kind
of fairly simple and kind of besides the
point
we really want this to be at all all
right so um so some progress if you mean
recently towards resolving this
conjecture as we've managed to show this
for a multiplayer version so what's a
multiplayer version and the multiplayer
version are we have capital and players
each player has an input in zr1 to the m
and they have access to shared
randomness now the communication is
going to be sequential communication
where the player just sends a message to
the I cross verse player looks like this
and imagine that the message just
depends on the input X I and the
previous message if we can do something
slightly more general I'm gonna mention
in a second but for now let's say the
message just depends on the on your only
input than the previous message
and again in the end the final player
outputs half of the sum of all these
acts earbuds
so in this setting the theorem we can
show this us up on ECCC that if the
number of players capital n is
sufficiently large and it has to be at
least ten times M then if there is a
protocol where each message m I is at
most C bets then we can construct a
randomized after sketch of size of C and
so it reads like any protocol that can
do whatever send some nonlinear things
we can construct a protocol that is
basically active capturing with only a
constant loss here so this is just some
fixed universal constant it doesn't
depend on anything that definitely does
not depend on anything and maybe maybe
Shahar remembers what the constant is
actually pretty small right
okay great
so this can also be generalized to 2zp
so again exactly pretty much the same
setting we have these inputs but now
over Z P to the M
so here we are going to incur log P loss
in Cabal places so first of all we are
going to increase the number of players
by factor of log P and second notice
that now there is a difference between
the dimension and the actual bit
complexity of the sketch so the
dimension of the sketch of HC P is going
to be order C but the bit complexity is
going to be a lot we factor large
all right so and that's basically all I
want to say it today about ZP for the
rats we're gonna focus on the field of
two elements is it important well so
yeah so we can talk about us a little
bit later where we can allow some
generalizations we're gonna allow some
approximation when F is not boolean etc
etc right so so there are some
generalizations of us we called not not
only for boolean functions but but then
you know there's gonna be some somewhat
dependents on some other parameters
all right so some motivation for of this
line of research and why did we decide
to you know study study all these
communication games as well comes from
distributing computing and streaming so
imagine our we are in a distributed
computing set setting where we have a
bunch of inputs x1 through XM are
divided between M machines or more
generally many our X is just the sum of
these M distributed inputs
so then on to scattering or sketching or
ecp yes it's very convenient to perform
in this distributed scenario because
everyone can just compute these sketches
locally and send them to the coordinator
who can then compute the overall linear
sketch by just summing up a coordinate
wise linear sketches that have been
received and this gives a coordinator
protocol where the coordinator only gets
K times M communication so that's a
sketch of dimension K from each of the M
players and another motivation is is the
streaming setting so in the streaming
setting imagine we start what ax wishes
initially just all zeros and then we
receive updates for each update is just
the coordinate in acts and that
coordinate we're just going to flap
updates like last one three three then
we just flip the first coordinate third
coordinate faith coordinate and then
flip the third coordinate back from one
to zero
and again you can notice that on a
linear sched can allow us to recover
artifacts with key bits of space where I
disregard the de storage of assets we're
going to talk about us in a second
industry main setting specifically all
right and so uh also there is a
connection between say the length of the
stream here and the number of players on
I'm not sure if that's super clear right
now but um eventually you know we're
gonna show that if you show a lower
bound for the communication game that's
also going to imply that we can
distribute ah the player's inputs amount
of players and sort of think of them as
streaming updates yes sorry that was not
super clear um alright so essentially
this is gonna imply optimality of
processing streaming updates or of these
form as long as your as your stream is
sufficiently long and so for example
from from this result that I mentioned
about the multiplayer version the
overall length of the stream would have
to be order n squared because we're
gonna have to have linear number of
players in an and each one has m bets so
if you think of all these players inputs
as updates then the overall length of
the stream would be quadratic in am
alright some frequently asked questions
a lot of good questions so far on but
everyone had some more some frequently
asked questions or why are we looking at
two updates instead of plus minus one in
fact as it turns out for a lot of
applications on even if you know the
sign of update are to your underline
input whether it goes from 0 to 1 or
from 1 to 0 doesn't really matter that
much
although there are some exceptions
so another frequently asked question but
I think someone already mentioned lives
do we store these random shots in the
streaming settings specifically you can
do randomized streaming algorithms using
Nissan's pseudo-random generator which
only introduces an extra log and factor
in space so that's why I mentioned
earlier if we don't really worry about
this storage all these random sets some
obligations so what application that I
think us it's by interesting is dynamic
graph streaming algorithms have been
recently shown are in the last few years
to me basically based pretty much all of
them on this primitive called l0
sampling and l0 sampling can be done
optimally using after scattering has
been shown last year so basically ah
this is maybe the most important
application
and another question often asked this
why are why do we want to compute f
exactly so far we're trying to compute
up exactly why not do this approximately
and I'm going to talk about this later
which is any function which has a nice
you know what's a good example to start
with yeah we're gonna get with us that's
gonna be like the bulk of the talk today
very various different examples on
all right yeah there any screaming
examples where you know f2 updates are
definitely not sufficient it's not
sufficient intensity or something yeah
so uh so one example is gonna be a
majority function high in the boolean
siding
all right so on so Kate do to introduce
what what you can actually sketching
basically our answer
modems question let's start with our
understanding first what can
deterministic sketches do versus what
randomize sketches can do so function f
has a deterministic sketch it turns out
even only yeah-ah
and this is kind of like a trivial
definition of what a deterministic
sketch really is you just take an
arbitrary function G over a collection
of key parties so this is just directly
what what a deterministic sketch else
but it turns out this is equivalent to
saying the following F has what is
called four-year dimension K and I
haven't described what that is yet but
turns out so that's property you can
quickly check using just the Fourier
spectrum of the function out and this is
a fairly folklore pack on so be known
for a while so explain what this means
in a second but this is kind of a
convenient way of checking you know
what's going on with the deterministic
sketch complexity rolling it and as it
turns out or randomisation can help a
lot for for say a disjunction of an
ambulance if I think an or a disjunction
of x1 through xn then are using this
free animation argument or or otherwise
you can really convince yourself that
there is nothing you can really do about
or deterministically if you compute at n
minus 1 fairies then you still need more
information about X and the response the
fact that or has free dimension equals m
with randomness sketching or is actually
very simple so if you want to sketch or
all you really want to know is is there
a single one that single bit that equals
to one
your input and to check that just pick a
bunch of random subsets it's one through
a steep
Salo gonna read out of them if you want
success probability 1 minus Delta and
what you want to make sure is you know
that one of these subsets catches this
input that's equal to 1 and if if that
happens and if also you parity values to
1 then you're gonna get a 1 in in the
outcome of your linear sketch and so
that's gonna happen basically with
probability 1/4 so that gives you output
of 1 so this is a motivational example
for when randomized linear sketches can
be much superior to 1 to determine a
stick once useful to keep in mind to
understand better you know what's going
on in general but in your sketching
because we're gonna be alluding to this
example later alright so so now I
mentioned some free analysis let's go
over this real quick and a look at the
audience and I'm guessing that everyone
more or less is on top of the free
analysis here so I'm just gonna go
through super quickly I imagine we have
a function Maps you want to the entry 0
1 3 analysis we can apply an impatience
which we please yours with once once
with minus ones so all functions are
really gonna be mapping minus 1 1 to the
n into minus 1 1 then functions are as a
2 to the N dimensional vectors form a
vector space so we're gonna be thinking
our function f is just the step up to
the n values the top second factor then
the inner product and functions are
captures correlation if you if you scale
this inner product by divide anybody to
the minus n and gives a expectation over
uniformly random acts of f of X times G
of X
and only four boolean functions are it
holds that ah that the to norm is going
to be one after these scaling
all right so um keep active site every
function can be uniquely represented as
a multi linear polynomial and this
polynomial has basis functions
caius and the coefficients of thus a
multi linear polynomial are the Fourier
coefficients alright so on
backs of center tracks from free
announcers first of all up and how do
you compute hump how do you compute the
Fourier coefficients
all right so now also call this notion
of free dimension to talk about free
dimension we will have to think about
these free assets as which index the
Fourier coefficients as vectors
themselves in f2 to the M and so so we
have this at switch index the Fourier
coefficients are here
so that becomes a back door in up to the
VM and we say that a function f has a
dimension K there is a K dimensional
subspace of f2 to the N here which
contains all of the spectrum of our
function namely if I take the summation
of the Fourier coefficients squared in
the subspace a K then I'm gonna get a 1
which has the full the full spectrum
dimension of the Spirit to support its
action for yourself work oh sorry said
again
all right so on
and so why does this give us a
deterministic sketch right away that's
because if you just pick some arbitrary
basis of size K in in a K and compute
the values of the parodies over these
bases then we can compute the entire
summation of all these realizations and
get the felt the value of F right
because remember that in this setting I
think learning C which people often get
confused here in this setting we do know
all the three equations because the
function f is fixed what you don't know
is the values of all these parodies but
because the parodies I index by South's
in a key dimensional subspace or it's a
physis you just compute K of them on the
basis and the rest of the parodies you
can figure out just by linear
combinations another way to think of it
is butafter lee now transformation well
yeah exactly sure
alright alright so that's why I'm free
animation just gives you a generation
deterministically in your sketch right
away um okay so now we're gonna move on
to some last real facts and I like to
describe what you can do well in your
sketch and gives us a scenario of what
do you think of a function as a sort of
a simple function plus some kind of
noise so imagine that your function f
looks like a sum of two boolean
functions G and H and so far we know
that k-dimensional functions one should
be small on three dimensions are easy so
let's take this to be the easy part and
the me also some other part that we're
gonna call noise so H in this case is
going to be our new easy function and G
is gonna be a simple
so with deterministic sketching it turns
out and I think this is a very beautiful
we saw due to sun gall as that if your
function has small Fourier sparsity that
it also has a not really small Fourier
dimension so what I mean by that imagine
your function R has some number of
nonzero Fourier coefficients this is
also known as Fourier sparsity then it
turns out that somehow it is it's a free
a dimension is only square root so
actually some some log factor here it's
only basically up to Allah factor square
root of the sparsity so notice that this
can only possibly be true for for
boolean functions if the function on
here at hand was not boolean with
absolutely no way you know this could
happen because you could just make all
the Fourier coefficients be linearly
independent from each other but somehow
this constraint that the resulting
function has to be boolean imposes a
certain certain restriction on what the
Fourier dimension of this function can
be and it can only be squared sparsity
somehow it's a quite a surprising fact
and one consequence of our work is that
this can actually be improved even with
randomness and even under the assumption
that you input is uniform but so so one
example but when this cannot be improved
yes is a passing function actually H so
G actually nevermind G if if you want to
keep things simple just think G to be
zero right just think of H to be sort of
the only interesting part for a moment
here I just want to see things well
generally say maybe you can add some
like smokey dimension for
next thing that's a the three of them I
turn is an also square root of
dispersity cracked right right so
another we control with us is just
saying three dimensions most up to up to
sun block factor
all right so um
so now let's go one step forward and
talk about randomization
how can randomization our handle noise
so one type of noise if you've already
seen a basic example off as a sparse
noise in the original domain so imagine
that your function looks like an or
function so or function is basically
constant one just corrupt it on a single
input
so then basically you can generalize
this trick with random parodies and if
you take log off of the sparsity of your
noise function then that's gonna give
you a bound on on the after sketch
complexity here just but take that many
random parodies essentially that's
that's the only thing you should do here
and you can't really improve thus are in
terms of dependence on um on the
magnitude of the noise and a final
example here we shall also find very
interesting is from the work of broken
Smolinski
on one can derive another non-trivial
sketch that can handle for year l1 noise
imagine on the through year l1 norm of
your function is small that you can
construct a sketch whose complexity
depends quadratically on the fourier l1
norm of the noise here essentially
sketch boils down to sampling on
sampling parodies from the l1
distribution in the Fourier domain
alright so some examples of functions
what a small free l1 norm would be
something like a small decision 3d
enough some such time
all right so um so now let's talk about
some some technical results um so how
can we our show a hardness result for
for randomized interruptions so we
talked about about a bunch of upper
bound so far here is one tool that you
can use to show hardness of randomized
linear scattering so if you can show
that the function is not well
concentrated on K dimensional Fourier
subspaces then are we gonna get a lower
bound and by are not concentrated I mean
that for every K dimensional Fourier
subspace a the sum of squared Fourier
coefficients outside of a is at least
one minus gamma so this means that you
don't have more than gamma fraction of
the spectrum inside any K dimensional
subspace
so that we can show that any
k-dimensional after sketches will be
making error that depends on gamma but
think of gamma is a constant for a
moment say 0.1 then you're going to be
making some constant error here average
oh that's a great question so vessels
actually gonna hold even our over
uniform distribution of X
mom so the converse of thus does not
hold so concentration on a low
dimensional fourier subspace will not
imply that you have a good sketch so
that would only be true in the
distributional setting that might be
basically asked about
all right so uh and this is how you can
immediately get some some basic results
about f2 sketching you can show that
functionaries which are not gamma
concentrated on sub linear dimensional
for your subspaces or almost all
symmetric functions of as long as you're
symmetric function is not fully a close
to a constant or OS a parody of all the
bets for example majority yes is another
good example here it's a symmetric
function another closely constant so you
get immediately a linear lower bound for
that and here I can dimension it's not
an extractor if you have an exactor then
you can also get rubber bands from exact
or zero um alright so some other
examples which are non symmetric or
tribes you can get a lower bound for
tribes for functions like recursive
majority and I think for quite a few
always recursive things like this you
can get lower bounds from from this
concentration argument
all right so on
so it's natural to to make a definition
here and say that we can introduce this
notion of approximate for your dimension
so this is just a recap of what you
already know so let's define the
approximate for your dimension to be the
smallest integer d such that f is gamma
concentrated on some free subspace of
dimension D the dimension are gamma F so
just a simple illustration in enough to
the end this would be let's say a three
dimensional subspace and I want to find
this smallest D in this case let's say
maybe D equals three so that at least
the gamma fraction of my sum of squares
is contained inside this three
dimensional subspace
all right so so free dimension is gonna
help us in a distributional setting as
as I already mentioned sketching over
the uniform distribution is in fact
characterized by this fourier dimension
so imagine that now we measure in error
not for arbitrary acts but ax is
uniformly distributed over 0 1 to the M
the simplest argument would show that if
you manage to capture epsilon fraction
of your spectrum in a substitution of
dimension D then you immediately get a
sketch with error one minus Epsilon
so basically you're gonna fix your sub
space that has has enough of the
spectrum and then you get just going to
output the sign of truncated free
expression just over over these
dimensional subspace and that's going to
give you error 1 minus epsilon so that's
actually a sender Center district coming
from the learning theory literature and
that means that over a uniform
distribution of X probably that geobox
agrees with f of X is at least Epsilon
so this is a little bit suboptimal in a
sense that say when absol is pretty
small your error is close to one but it
really should be should be close to half
so I'll be just we find this a little
bit and got the error to be what what it
should be
when absalom is small to be 1 minus
epsilon over 2 so the way to do this
here so you can refine this sine trick a
little bit by picking theta from a some
simple distribution so that's the
distribution of theta that we're going
to use and then on you take this for
your expansion or subtract theta from
this distribution and output G theta of
X exactly why it does as the right thing
to do actually I'm not sure on would be
great to actually have some intuition
for why for why thus this seems to be
seems to be a good thing to do so the
sketch is deterministic but the
Recovery's randomized
okay so I think you can do randomized if
you want that's yeah that's sort of a
simple way to describe but but you can
be randomized
all right so um so now let me connect
this whole discussion of weather with
communication complexity and um let's
start with uh with one way communication
complexity of these acts or functions so
this is basically what I stated on in
the open problem up front imagine we
have these two players I'll sing Bob
they have access to hear randomness and
want to compute f plus f of X plus y so
Alice is sending a message ammo box to
Bob and some examples of the function f
plus if you take this composing function
f to be or then this is going to be f
plus is the not equal function of x and
y if if you take the composing function
to be the number of nonzero is greater
than d this is going to be the Hamming
distance between x and y is greater than
d function
so let's introduce notation that the
one-way communication complexity with
error epsilon of the function f plus
there's just the shortest message which
allows Bob to compute f plus with error
probability Epsilon
so communication complexity of XOR
functions as as well studied and
recently there's been a lot of interest
so it's usually studied on though in the
in literature in two-way communication
setting sometimes distributive sometimes
a sorry sometimes deterministic
sometimes randomized and there's been a
lot of interesting results on these
lately
and some of the interest specifically in
acts or functions comes from the fact
that the log-rank conjecture is still
open even for these special class of
functions
but before we talk about randomize let's
talk about deterministic from quack and
this is something that I personally find
a pretty fascinating
so deterministic one-way communication
complexity of XOR functions
turns out to be exactly equal to they're
apt to sketch complexity all right so in
deterministic case we don't have any
randomness you know alice is just
sending this one message to Bob and what
has always to output the correct answer
and from this world by Montanaro and
Osborne it shows it falls directly
basically in a very simple one-line
argument that the communication
complexity exactly equals to the linear
sketch complexity I notice there is
absolutely no loss here there is no
additive multiplicative or anything
factors just exactly as a Fourier
dimension right so and this is a
critical part of this argument on is
that both of these quantities are
basically exactly equal to the three
dimension of F and and the reason why
this is fairly simple to show is because
the deterministic one-way communication
complexity from al-shabaab is just
really really simple it's just log of
the number of different rows in the
communication matrix and then and then
you can relay this directly to the R to
the free dimension
but randomized one-way communication
complexity of XOR functions it is
somehow noticeably more complicated it's
not just log of the number different
rows in the communication matrix it
actually does not have a particular very
simple our characterization well as far
as I know
but but they strike in fact that in
Venice no mr. cases to quantities or
exactly equal is exactly the motivation
behind our conjecture here which
basically says that our
maybe these quantities are approximately
or even exactly the same given in the
randomized case right so these are just
appropriate definitions of randomized
linear sketch complexity one-way
communication and so one direction of
this is straightforward because Alice
can just just send parodies to Bob Bob
computes the parodies of of his input
and and uses that to compute the
parodies for X X or Y and then recovers
out Sebastien s s inequality between the
other direction so do you have examples
to show that it's actually not equal you
know um as far as I know I think could
could read that equal
isn't that the open question you
mentioned earlier yeah yeah yeah that's
right so so we finally sort of get back
to you know just read open cross all
right so um so that's a bastion and
basically using it in our work we can
show that this holds for like a lot of
usual candidates are various counter
examples in free analysis majority
tribes recursive majority addressing
function almost all symmetric functions
and for degree D of two polynomials on
we can show this for the loss of a
factor of D so if you want to construct
a counter example then your counter
example should better be a fairly large
degree F two polynomial
analogous question for two-way
communication yes it's pretty wide open
so the sious from the work of Hitomi
Cassini and Lovett who asked is
apparently decision tree complexity
polynomially related to the two-way
communication complexity of the
corresponding acts or function
and in the distributional setting if ax
and y are sampled uniformly from 0 1 to
the M this also holds of this conjecture
and that's basically how we get a lot of
these results of that I mentioned on the
previous slide so in the distributional
case on just you can define you know the
decrease phoning communication
complexity appropriately this is just a
the yellowest principle here and the
distributional communication complexity
for the uniform distribution is just
going to be the smallest message that
Alice sends to Bob that allows Bob to
compute f of X Y for beginning from the
random x and y
so if the distribution of selling is
enough to consider only domestic
massagers and some motivation are going
back to streaming and distributed would
be to say that you know instrument
similar case maybe maybe our input is
uniformly random
all right so uh and as I mentioned the
this result does hold for for for these
distributional signing over the uniform
distribution so uh in the distributional
setting we can show that basically again
this approximate for your dimension up
to some constant factors here and there
controls controls the communication
complexity off of this communication
problem
and yeah so this is optimal applicants
and factors in dimension in error
because the D dimensional in your sketch
else as we discussed earlier has error 1
minus epsilon over 2 so here we get 1
minus epsilon over sex and the dimension
is it's optimal up to some factor is X
again here all right so some some
applications of this result for the
uniform distribution imagine that that
you have an input X that is generated by
a stream of updates and then we update
just flips a uniformly random coordinate
and the goal is to maintain f of X while
the stream question how much space is
necessary and the answer is basically
the the approximate Fourier dimension it
is right answer because as as we
discussed this is up to up to some
constant factors this approximate
Fourier dimension
and major Op a question here SS true
when X is not uniform so in the
streaming setting this is indeed true
for very very very long streams and very
very very means to tripley exponential
dependence on em and these needs to be
for others why this really nice resolved
by leaning and and Buddha adopted to
there are two hour setting that if your
stream is extremely long then there is
nothing better you can do but for
updates over f2 we can also show this
for streams of land only quadratic in an
why these recent results are then
imagine
all right and to conclude here are some
highlights of the extensions that we got
recently approximate after sketching
should have been a bit of a follow up
for the Samsungs you want us so in the
approximate setting we have a function
that now is is real valued and it's
convenient to normalize it you have to
norm across one so in this case it turns
out a a good nice definition to be
working with as expected squared error
so here for every X in expectation over
the random sets we want to have error at
most at most epsilon in there
so some interesting facts if you pick
this definition what the expected
squared error then under the uniform
distribution basically everything is
going to generalize this notion of
approximate free dimension is going to
control the sketching complexity over
the uniform distribution with this
notion of approximation with expected
squared error an interesting fact is
that this lvl1 sampling in fact cannot
be improved for for approximate
scattering for boolean functions
actually don't know what are these
dependents on the four-year l1 norm is
optimal for scattering
so this joint work for the Samsung or
each other s what you can do in terms of
approximate scattering of valuation
functions starting with something very
simple basically just just a linear
function moving on to something more
complex like coverage functions Metroid
ranks where we have various results
depending on the rank or of of the
metroid run function we also looked at
off ellipses the modular functions where
we get get some lower bounds so just a
quick one slide summary of obvious joint
work and that's questions
just think creative impact Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]